children too. If you've got a Bible please turn with me to Exodus. Exodus 34. We'll have
one finger there. And then if you could also turn to 2 Corinthians chapter 3 and have another
finger there. We'll kind of give equal time and weight to both of those this morning as
we start nearing the end of our series in Exodus. You can also look at your worship
diet. It's on there, but the page runs out right before it gets to the key verse that
the whole thing is based on. So you might miss out on that important bit just so you
know. Yesterday I visited with family who had just come back from the beach. It's that
time of year. And even if I hadn't known that they had just come back from the beach
you could tell it because it was all over their face with the sun that they got while
they were there. Last week we were seeing that Moses was looking on the radiance of God's
glory. And this week we're going to see that you could literally see that the effect of
God's shining glory on Moses's very face. So let's read this accounts together. In
fact we don't always do this, but could we stand as we read the Word of God together?
Exodus chapter 34 beginning with verse 29. When Moses came down from Mount Sinai with
the two tablets of the testimony in his hand as he came down from the mountain, Moses
did not know that the skin if his face shown because he had been talking with God. Aaron
and all the people of Israel saw Moses and behold the skin if his face shown and they
were afraid to come near him. But Moses called to them and Aaron and all the leaders of the
congregation returned to him and Moses talked with them. Afterward all the people of Israel
came near and he commanded them all that the Lord had spoken with him in Mount Sinai.
And when Moses had finished speaking with them he put a veil over his face. Whenever
Moses went in before the Lord to speak with him he would remove the veil until he came out.
And when he came out and told the people of Israel what he was commanded the people of
Israel would see the face of Moses that the skin of Moses face was shining and Moses
would put the veil over his face again until he went in to speak with him. So now we're
looking at 2 Corinthians in chapter 3. We'll begin reading in verse 7. Now if the ministry
of death carved in letters on stone came with such glory that the Israelites could not
gaze at Moses face because of its glory which was being brought to an end will not the ministry
of the Spirit have even more glory for if there was glory in the ministry of condemnation
the ministry of righteousness must far exceeded in glory indeed in this case what once had
glory has come to have no glory at all because of the glory that surpasses it for what if what
was being brought to an end came with glory much more will what is permanent have glory.
Since we have such a hope we are very bold not like Moses who would put a veil over his
face so that the Israelites might not gaze at the outcome of what was being brought to an end
but their minds were hardened for to this day when they read the Old Covenant the same veil
remains unlifted because only through Christ is it taken away. Yes to this day whenever
Moses is read a veil lies over their hearts but when one turns to the Lord the veil
is removed. Now the Lord is the Spirit and where the Spirit of the Lord is there
is freedom and we all with unveiled face beholding the glory of the Lord are being
transformed into the same image from one degree of glory to another for this comes
from the Lord who is the Spirit this is the word of the Lord. And so may the Lord
open our eyes to behold wondrous things in his word to take a seat. Last week we
saw that God gave Moses this glimpse of glory and proclaimed his name the Lord the Lord
merciful and gracious slow to anger and abounding in steadfast love and
faithfulness and this was really the high point of his time with the Lord on
Mount Sinai but this wasn't the totality of the time that he spent with the
Lord on Sinai to kind of pick up where we left off we're told that
Moses was there for 40 days and 40 nights like we had seen him before on another
trip up the mountain and during that time the Lord gave him the word that he was
to proclaim to his people and central to what he was to tell them was the Ten
Commandments so he gives them the Ten Commandments again and he has him
write them on two tablets of stone. There's some discussion asked what was
happening there exactly so whether or not all the commandments were written across
two tablets of stone but there there's also one suggestion that it could have
been actually all the commandments were written on one of the stone tablets and
then they were rewritten on another one of the stone tablets. We can't be for
sure exactly which way it happened although it's often depicted with
Moses with kind of half of the Ten Commandments on one half on the
other but it's an interesting thought that you could have had to because
or duplicates because you get that with a contract don't you? We've got both parties
have that kind of contract agreement in front of them here and this is
really what these commandments are pointing towards because remember Israel
has this covenant relationship with the Lord and in his law he is spelling
out what their relationship with him is supposed to look like in practice.
So this is how they walk in light of this covenant relationship with their
Lord. So when we come to our passage this morning Moses is now returning with
these tablets in hands. He has these new tablets because remember what when he
came down the last time he he was angry as he saw the people worshiping this
idol this golden calf and so he smashed these tablets. He had this shocking
sight seeing the people worshiping this false God but now that he comes
back with this new set of tablets we actually have another shocking sight
here but this time it isn't what Moses sees that is shocking it is what the
people see that is shocking. So let's read verses 29 and 30 again says when he
came down from Sinai Moses did not know that the skin of his face shown
because he had been talking with God Aaron and all the people of Israel saw
Moses and behold the skin of his face shown and they were afraid to come
near him. I mean can you imagine what it would have been like to see Moses' face
shining as he came down from the mountain. It was so bizarre that it frightened the
people and it's maybe even slightly more bizarre than we first realize as we
read this here because you know this unusual sight is something that
artists over the centuries have depicted in some unusual ways and I'm going to
bring this up because I know that this was actually brought up in our men's
group me recently because artists over the years have depicted Moses as
having horns. Now this is freaky when you see this yes you heard me right so
you look at for example so Michelangelo is known for his sculpture of David
when you see a similar sculpture of Moses Moses has got a couple of horns on
his head. You think what is going on here? This is some like satanic reference
what's what's happening? Well the reason for this is in the Latin Vulgate which
is like an early translation of the Bible they actually translated this
passage here the word for shown which is repeated they actually translated
that as he was horned as he came down from the mountain. Now as wild as that
sounds that is really the most literal rendering of the word that is used for
shining here. Now to be clear before you think I've just lost it light is
emanating from Moses' face there's a reason why this is translated as shown
we're gonna see that in a moment so as you read 2nd Corinthians 3 and 4 it's
making it very clear Moses' face is shining. Why is this word used here?
Here's a little suggestion it could be that this is a reversal of what
happens the last time that Moses came down from Sinai. Remember they had been
worshiping this false image this golden calf but now God is revealing his glory
truly through Moses who is a true image bearer and representative of his glory.
Alright that's interesting for sure some level of uncertainty there so let's move
back into here's what we can know for certain this is what we want to emphasize
is the certain things. Well like horns projecting from an animal Moses has
got light projecting from his face it's emanating outward and that light
that is emanating outward from Moses' face is a reflection of the very radiance
of God's glory so he's just seen the glory of God so you can imagine like
looking at the moon and as you're looking at the light of the moon you're
also looking at a reflection of the Sun this is what's going on with the
light that's shining from Moses' face it's a reflection of the glory of God
another thing that is certain here the glory of God is something that is not
only seen it is also heard we saw that last week Moses saw the glory of God
revealed and as he's looking the Lord proclaims his name so he's seeing and
hearing the glory of God at the same time and the same thing is going to
happen here so Moses comes down his face is shining so the people are seeing
the glory of God and as they're seeing it Moses is proclaiming the word of
God so people are seeing the glory of God as the word of God is being
proclaimed and that same pattern continues on to this day God invites us to
see his glory by hearing the glory he has revealed in his word he shows us his
glory through the proclamation of his word alright so that's what's
happening here in this passage right Moses is shining his face is there
he's proclaiming the word he's proclaiming God's commands to his people
also turn with me over to 2 Corinthians chapter 3 we might be thinking well how
does that account that story apply to us and the apostle Paul takes this and
he shows how it applies in very specific ways he talks about how the new
covenant this covenant that we are invited this relationship with God
that we are invited into through Christ is more glorious than the old
covenant that we see depicted in Exodus 34 and elsewhere in the Old Testament
and he also talks about how the glory of this new covenant is also seen in the
lives of those who have been transformed by it alright so what are we looking
at as we're looking at Moses his face shining well the apostle Paul is
going to help us here we'll look at a couple things one as we see Moses his
face shining as you're proclaiming his word it's to point us to the fact
that we are pointed to a greater glory in Christ so the greater glory that we
are called to see is the very glory of Jesus so in credit second Corinthians
chapter actually it's over in chapter 4 and the kind of culmination of what he's
been saying in 3 he talks about the light of the glory of Christ so the
vision of glory that we are invited to see today is greater than the
vision of glory that we see on Moses face because it's the very light of the
glory of Christ alright so back in Exodus 34 you've got this reflection of
God's glory as Moses spoke but the glory that we see in Jesus is far
brighter how is it brighter alright chapter 3 verses 1 to 12 you've got the
glory of the old covenant that you see in the law contrasted with the glory of the
new the the old covenant was good but the glory of Christ is even better it's
surpassing and because it's surpassing it's that that's surpassing nature of
Christ glory now much better it is shows that the the glory of the old
covenant was good but it was temporary whereas the glory of Christ is meant
to shine forever a more simple way of saying that would be I remember going
hunting with my dad when I was a kid and it didn't take it was cold it was early
in the morning I wasn't a fan of it and I remember us going out early in the
morning you know before before dawn even we'd get out of the truck and we'd go
and we'd have our little flashlights going through the woods to get to where
we needed to go but it wasn't long before those flashlights were no
longer needed because the the sun would come out so it's the flashlight was
good and it was necessary but it wasn't meant to to be on throughout the
whole day because of the greater sun shining so this is the kind of argument
of Paul here is like yes the old covenant was good but we're living in the light
of Christ today and see this this much brighter greater glory that shines
forever in second Corinthians chapter 4 once again verses 4 to 6 we see that
it is in Jesus face rather than Moses face that we're invited to see the
light of the knowledge of the glory of God truly in other words Jesus is the
true and better Moses who perfectly shines forth the glory of God she's have
this imperfect picture in Moses perfect picture in Jesus or another place we
could go to see the glory of God revealed in Jesus and how it's greater than
Moses is in Jesus Transfiguration in Matthew 17 it's interesting there
Jesus goes up a mountain with three of his disciples listen to what it says
about what happened there Matthew 17 verse 2 it says in Jesus was transfigured
before them and his face shone like the sun and his clothes became white as
light so there's that vision of glorious face shining like the sun and then it
says verse 5 behold a bright cloud overshadowed them and a voice from the
cloud said this is my beloved son with whom I am well pleased listen to him
she's got this vision of glory in Jesus and who Jesus is his goodness his name
being proclaimed at the same time so see the glory of God in the face of
Jesus shining like the sun the thing about the glory of that was emanating
from Jesus is this it wasn't a mere reflected glory like we see in Moses it
was emanating from the very essence of his being so Moses is reflecting the
glory of God whereas Jesus is the very radiance of the glory of God as it
says in Hebrews 1 verse 3 he is the light of the glory of God because he
is God manifested in flesh so Jesus is more glorious but also Jesus brought
about something more glorious he brought about this greater covenant this
relationship that we can know with the Lord now so why is our relationship
with the Lord now better than that old covenant relationship that the people
of Israel knew with the Lord well several reasons are here let me just
rattle off a few one it's better because he gives us life you know the law that
Moses gave was good but it cannot change anyone's heart in fact it reveals our
sinfulness under the law we stand condemned that's why it is called verse
7 the ministry of death in verse 9 it's referred to as the ministry of
condemnation so Christ gives us something better here's what he gives he gives
his life and he was condemned in our place and he gives the spirit who gives
us a new life and brings us into a relationship with the living God and
he gives us new hearts that want to know the Lord and to live for him in
Jesus we have a living knowledge of the true and living God so he gives us
life the law couldn't do that you point us to Jesus but it cannot give us life
that comes through Christ alone but he also gives us greater access you see
that in verses 4 and 5 of chapter 3 in the people when they saw the reflection
that was on Moses's face we read that they were afraid but through Christ we're
told that we have confidence toward God and that confidence doesn't come from
looking to ourselves our sufficiency it says is not of ourselves our
sufficiency is from God so Christ gives us confidence to come into the presence
of the living God as we heard Luke sharing just a moment ago like a child
coming to their father it's also greater because in Jesus we have a greater
vision of the glory of God in verse 18 we're told that through Christ we
behold God with unveiled face we behold his glory with an unveiled face you know
the people of Israel had this veil so let's let's go look Paul uses this
imagery of the veil over Moses's face to speak about how the people don't truly
see today the glory of Christ in Scripture it's like a veil is over their eyes
if you go to chapter 4 it describes it as Satan blinding people's eyes so that they
don't see the glory of Christ revealed in his word it's like a veil is over their
face keeping them from seeing his glory in the word but then it says here's
what happens how does that change how do we come to truly see the glory of
Christ well the Spirit of God sets us free he removes the veil he shows us
the glory of Jesus chapter 4 and verse 6 it talks about how the God who spoke
creation into being saying let there be light shines on our hearts to give us
the light of the knowledge of the glory of God in the face of Jesus so how do we
see Jesus's glory the Spirit of God opened our eyes to see Jesus's glory
what does that look like on a human level okay the Spirit of God open our
eyes well it tells us it is in turning to the Lord that the veil is removed you
see that in chapter 3 and verse 16 so we're told to turn from our sin turn to
the Lord put our faith in him when we put our faith in Jesus we see that it's
Christ who truly sets us free and brings us into a true knowledge of the Lord
it's in him that we see the glory of God and as that happens we praise God
because it's his spirit who has brought that about showing us this Christ who we
are looking to by faith so in Moses face we see this reflection of the glory that
we come to see truly in Jesus alright but let's move on you got this greater
glory in Jesus but then you have this greater transformation that takes place
so let's read verse 18 once again says and we all with unveiled face
beholding the glory of the Lord are being transformed into the same image from
one degree of glory to another for this comes from the Lord who is the Spirit
so what we have is greater because there's a greater transformation that
takes place and takes place as we behold the glory of God in the face
of Jesus I don't know if you've ever noticed this I'm sure you have but
like as couples have been together for a long time years even decades some of
them start to look a lot like each other I don't know is it just me you know they
start to walk like each other and talk like each other and I started looking
this a little bit and apparently there are some studies out there that
shows that because of like we mimic each other in conversation like if you
talk with somebody for decades like your your faces are literally mimic each
other all the time and so you develop wrinkles in the same places so
you're literally being transformed into it's a kind of resembling one another so
beholding results in becoming we're designed that way I mean same it's true
of little children like little children how do they learn to walk and to talk
and their particularities of how they do that what it's it's who they are
watching they're watching their parents and they're embodying the very
things that they are seeing so beholding results in becoming this is the
invitation to a greater transformation that we see here as we behold the glory
of Christ we become more like him right so we fix our eyes on his face on who
he is his being his person and that is what changes us also what are we
transformed into as we behold Jesus we are transformed into verse 18 the same
image of the one we're beholding the scripture speaks of God's face shining
upon us we we read that earlier in Psalm 67 he makes his glorious goodness known
to us and that's described as his face shining upon us but that's similar
language of his face shining is used to talk about the transforming effect the
Lord has in the lives of his people as they look to him so Psalm 34 and verse
five here what it says those who look to him are radiant and their faces shall
never be ashamed so what's the result of people who see the radiance of God's
glory they are radiance what happens to us as we behold the glory the beauty the
majesty of Jesus we are transformed to be people who radiate his glory in the
world we become more like him by the way as we reflect his glory we are enabled to
be his witnesses in the world Philippians chapter 2 and verse 15 says that we shine
as lights in the world holding forth the word of life alright so we were
transformed into him his image how does that happen as we behold his glory by
his spirit in his word now we spoke about that earlier but more as like
conversion like how we come to first see Jesus but the same is true in terms of our
ongoing relationship with him it is by his spirit through his word that we see
more and more and more of who Jesus is as we pray as Moses did show me more of
your glory remember there's a connection between seeing the glory of God and
hearing the word of God and that continues on that's how we see him
so seeing the glory of Jesus isn't just some like vague fuzzy feel good
spiritual thing it's it's seeing somebody specific whose name is Jesus it is
seeing that the specificity of his his attributes in his word it's coming to
know more and more of who Jesus is and the beauty of that and that's sure with
there's an experience that goes along with that we're not talking we're not
building a vision of Jesus based on that experience we're having our eyes
open to see the Jesus who's revealed in his word we come to see more of the Christ
who's revealed here this is what compels us to keep looking you know when it
talks about beholding him it's a it's a word for like hunger and desire to
that like we want to see more of him we're saying Lord show me more of your
glory and that's what changes us so Hebrews 12 verses 1 and 2 says it in
a different way using a different metaphor says remember we're to run the
race that's set before us laying aside the the weight and sin that easily
besets us how are we to lay aside our sin and to run with patience
Hebrews 12 to looking to Jesus the author and finisher of our faith that's a
continual word there to continual gaze he's the one who has our
attention how can we turn away from sinful desires that we wrestle with
and fail and drop into over and over again by remembering that Jesus is better
and turning our eyes back to him again and again and again how can our
disorder desires where we treat good things as as ultimately as ultimate
things how can we how can we deal with that well by turning our eyes to
Jesus and see that yes there are good things in the world and like we sure
we enjoy nature we enjoy music and we can list all kinds of good beautiful
things in the world but what we're hearing what we are seeing is reflected glory
those aren't the ultimate things and so we enjoy them in a way where we're
giving thanks and glorifying God through the enjoyment so we're not treating
those good things as ultimately ultimate things it's all about the glory of
Jesus who's better than the sinful things and he's also the one who
gives us the good things it's his glory that is shining all right so it's by
holding his glory in his word another thing that kind of encourages me here is
that's by degree as well from glory to glory
this is not our justification by the way our justification is God declaring us
righteous in Jesus all right that's already been given to us through faith in him
that's a one and done but our sanctification this is our ongoing lifelong process of becoming
more like Jesus and that happens from degree to degree uh i wonder how you're doing in that
i'm moving from one degree of glory to another uh i'm i've got a long way to go um i chuckled
this past week because it made me think of a news article that pops up from time to time it
always happens where somebody there's a a statue that's commissioned of somebody
and it turns out terribly you know you think of you look up christiano rinaldo and there's this
like really deformed uh bust that's out there somewhere people are horrified as they're seeing
this image or you get lucile ball statue in her hometown that was not so affectionately referred
to as scary luci like you would not want to see it in the dark i think they eventually had to
remove it um so you have these images but they are not exactly right and so when i think okay
i'm supposed to reflect the glory of christ it's not exactly right here
but the good news is god is not finished that's not the finished product he's working on us
you know one of the ironic things too about living in the light of jesus beholding his glory is
that it reveals even more of our sinfulness like the longer you know him the more you see of him
the also the more you see of yourself and that could that could totally be discouraging but
after we look at ourselves that shows us how he's even more merciful than we realized he loves us
even more than we realize because if he sees this about me and he still loves me he's even greater
than i imagined that's why i love the scottish pastor robert murray mcshane he said for every
one look itself take ten looks at christ it's necessary to see where we fall short but keep
looking again and again to jesus and as we look at him for example and we're becoming more
aware of his mercy and how much he has forgiven us that will transform us into becoming more
merciful people people who are more ready to forgive others because if we've been forgiven
so much how could we hold a grudge against somebody else and not forgive them because
we're aware of our sin the greatness of christ's mercy and so that transforms us to becoming more
like christ in showing mercy to others and that could be said across the spectrum with so many other
beautiful attributes of jesus do we fail yes but god will finish the work that he began he is faithfully
at work in us bringing us from glory to glory showing us more of who he is and shaping us
into the likeness of his son and we hit justification and sanctification but hey this is all leading to
glorification as well that kind of degrees of change is that's leading somewhere and it's
leading to the day when we see christ and we are changed to be like him first drawn chapter three
in verse two says beloved we are god's children now and what we will be has not yet appeared
but we know that when he appears we shall be like him because we shall see him as he is there is
coming a day when our struggle with sin will be no more we will be made like christ we will
reflect his glory just as we were made to when we see him face to face last thing happens through
beholding jesus it happens by degree just to remind us as a place to land it happens supernaturally
so yes i want to call you keep looking to jesus i do want to call you keep opening up his word
get in this book daily for sure do that keep fighting sin the distractions of the world that
keep you from looking to jesus but in all of that remember as it says at the end of verse 18
this comes from the lord it's not our own grit that transforms us it's the lord who transforms
us by his spirit he's made you his own and he is more committed to your sanctification than you are
look to him when it feels like it's going well because it's him doing it and when you fail look
to him because he's going to be the one who's going to pick you up and put you back on the
right track this is why paul can say in flippians 1 6 i am sure of this that he who began a good
work in you will bring it to completion at the day of christ jesus let's pray
lord help us to see and to keep looking at the glory of jesus and lord in beholding his glory lord i
pray that we would become the people that you have created us to be that from glory to glory
we would be changed into the likeness of your son and lord we thank you so much that this is
ultimately your work lord as we look at ourselves lord we see all the deficiencies that are there
and the distorted parts of our lives but lord we thank you that you've given us everything
that we need in christ to be transformed in his likeness so lord i pray that you'd help us
to keep looking to him in the hope of that day when we see him face to face we pray all this in his name